it's so wonderful to connect with you i
mean talk about
being in isolation but at the same time
creating some
incredible content and your career is
just like
i mean what is your mood right now with
everything that's happening for you i
mean
yo you just got to take it day by day
today i feel really good
the birds are out chirping the sun is
shining so
i can't really complain yeah and how has
it been for you to create music in
in isolation uh it's definitely been a
unique experience you know
yeah i i kind of credited to a lot of my
success that i had this year because
before you know i was just working with
a bunch of different producers but
this pandemic um forced me to lock in
with the real
team of people that i find we work
consistently well together and
just always make great music so i was
able to do that and i think that's why
the music i'm making is so great right
now i love that there's a lot of passion
behind that i mean
the last time we spoke to your mother
wasn't really happy by the idea that you
left a
full scholarship pursue music how is she
feeling now and she's like yo
this is so great she's like yo sending
me house links on zillow i'm like
we're wait we'll figure it out mom don't
worry don't worry
but she must be proud of you of course
she is yeah she's very very proud
she calls me every week and he's like yo
you want to do some breathing exercises
like i know it gets stressful
and sometimes i'm like you know what mom
that would actually be really nice
oh and you're really blowing up i mean
there's a lot of people loving your
music especially with
the release of your single mood uh are
you noticing your stardom starting to
grow and
people are connecting with you a lot
more fans you know i always felt like
the biggest star in the world
it's now just world is you know kind of
catching on let's say
we could put it like that but yeah 100
like
all the love and support that i got this
year has been like
incredible and like nothing else i've
ever had happen before so
shout out to the world shout out to the
world
who slipped into your dms is that the
right term slipped into your dms is
there any celebrities that have like hey
we want to say hi yeah there's there's a
there's a couple
yeah like who a gentleman doesn't kiss
and tell
you that doesn't doesn't dm and tell
any celebrity doesn't have to be an
email i mean
like um miranda cosgrove did like a
video with the song
like donald glover like used it it's
just weird like
the craziest like hugest celebrities
that i looked at and watched as a kid
i had no idea what i was doing now like
love my music so that's kind of fire
now here you are with an album uh
congratulations to you i mean this is a
feeling for any artist to release a
sophomore
album uh how would you describe the vibe
of this album
well i consider it my debut album
because the last project was the ep
so i've put like a lot of concentrated
effort into making sure that it sounds
cohesive and tells a story because
i'm trying to create my own world you
know the real world right now
isn't in the best of places so i want to
make something that people can
escape into sonically and visually and
either forget about their problems or at
least feel a little bit better about
their problems after listening to it so
in the past you know i made pop songs i
made rap songs i made rock songs but
what i've been able to do now with the
help of my really
talented friends that are producers is
combine everything
into one so it's not rap it's not rock
it's not
pop it's golden it's uniquely me and
it's just the best music i've made in my
life so i can't wait for y'all to hear
it oh
i love that and why is the name el
dorado
so el dorado is a nickname that i've had
since a kid and it means the golden one
but it also means the golden city based
off of this lost
ancient latin american city where
everything was gold you know they were
just
loaded up on it but the golden city is
also kind of like my hometown san
francisco you know we got the golden
gate bridge to go
state warriors so i was like this is a
combination of
me where i come from and what i want to
create into
into the world all together so el dorado
is there any collaborations on the
record plenty of collaborations
okay like who i mean you know we've
already got the baby and
ian dior on there i've got some of my
friends you know on their cash page
um recently linked up with i'm gonna
give y'all i'm gonna give y'all an
exclusive
recently linked up with uh sway lee in
the future so we got some of there and
you know maybe a couple more surprises
we'll see what happens
could one of the surprises be drake
because i know you really want to
collaborate with him
hey that's more of a question for you
canada you need to go put that call in
tell big bro let's put it out there
drake if you're watching
we want a collaboration see i'm helping
out
thank you very much your efforts are
appreciated
uh and your song mood i mean all the
success that's come with the single i
mean how does it feel that people have
really appreciated
the single itself i mean that's that's
all i wanted to do with my music is to
is to make music that's gonna impact how
people feel and just be heard you know
yeah the cars and the clothes and the
money that's cool i like that stuff too
but that was not my reason for getting
into this it was to be heard for what i
had to share with the world
and now that that's finally happening i
just i couldn't be more happy
yeah i know you talked about the cars
what was the first purchase you made
when you got that
big picture oh my god i i got a range
rover and then it broke down on me like
three weeks later and i returned it so
no i'm waking up on the cars for now i
got my eyes on a couple other things
right now but
yeah that definitely was disappointing
oh
no that does suck but okay well the next
time you get another another card that
you absolutely love but
uh going forward now with this album
having this hit
what do you see in the future in the
next five years for yourself
um five years i'll be 25
so still a lot of life left to live
after that but
by that time i want to be uh you know a
really respected established
uh musician for just creating my own
sound
um i want to be able to tour across the
world and and see
tens of thousands of my fans yeah with
me in crazy arenas you know
um i definitely want to get in my acting
bag more we're working on a tv show
right now based off my life
where i play like a version of myself um
so i want to explore that more on my
black vinnie chase watching a lot of
entourage
and probably just you know be a a
philanthropist and a businessman too and
give back to the places and the people
that helped me become who i am
so that other people can achieve their
full greatness and their full potential
i love that and the tv show is about
your life and you're so
young so what can we see in the tv show
when it comes to your
upbringing i might be young but i live a
lot of life i'll tell you that
tell me about it so basically when i
left
college uh i moved in with my friend's
family
um his mom is my agent and um
and it was just like a fresh prince of
bel-air
meets like entourage meets like uh curb
your enthusiasm type of situation
because
everybody in my life is a character of
their own and you got me this kid that
you know comes from
uh not the 90210 zip code at all you
know from
one of the the least expensive parts of
san francisco and one of the
you know it ain't that fabulous as
having a
maid come in and make your bed every day
and somebody do your laundry so it was a
very much so
a fish out of water story and um just
you know dealing with all the characters
in my life
dealing with the pressures of the music
industry and just
trying to make good songs that inspire
people
i love that congratulations i'm so
excited for you
i mean keep going keep growing and
wishing you all the best
thank you very much i appreciate your
time